[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: I'm Sarah.
I'm the engineering lead
for TensorFlow Lite.
And I'm really happy
to be back at I/O
again, talking about
TensorFlow Lite again.
TIM DAVIS: Woo-hoo.
Thank you to all of you
for joining us here today.
I'm Tim.
I'm the product manager
for TensorFlow Lite.
And today we're here to tell
you about doing machine learning
on mobile and IoT devices.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: So I
expect that most of you
here are already familiar
with what machine learning is,
so I won't be going into that.
But let's talk instead
about what is TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is Google's open
source, cross-platform machine
learning framework.
It allows you to
build your models
and deploy them to servers,
browsers, and all the way
to edge devices.
It's a full end-to-end
ecosystem which
goes all the way from
research to production,
from training in the data center
to deployment and edge like,
I said.
TensorFlow has support
for multiple languages--
Swift, JavaScript, and Python.
TIM DAVIS: So what is TensorFlow
Lite, and how does it fit in?
TensorFlow Lite is TensorFLow's
cross-platform framework
for deploying ML on mobile
devices and embedded systems.
You can take your
existing TensorFlow models
and convert them over to
TensorFlow Lite easily.
But I wanted to walk
you through why this
is so important to TensorFlow.
There has been a
global explosion
in Edge ML, driven by the
need for user experiences
that require low latency and
closer knit interactions.
Further drivers, like
poor network connectivity
in many geographical regions
around the world and user
privacy requirements, have
all fueled the need for ML
on device.
This has led to a whole
revolution of machine learning
and product innovation in nearly
every single industry vertical.
We see it all over
the place, driven
by on-device machine learning
running in environments that
utilize small compute, that have
a constrained memory capacity,
and consume low power.
So that's why the TensorFlow
team decided to invest heavily
in making it easy to
develop, build, and deploy ML
that is cross-platform capable.
TensorFlow Lite can be
deployed on Android, iOS,
Linux, and other platforms.
It's easier than ever
to use TensorFlow
and convert your model
to TensorFlow Lite
and deploy it anywhere.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN:
So at this point,
you might be wondering what can
you do with TensorFlow Lite.
We really want you to be able
to solve any kind of problem
that you can imagine
directly on the device.
And later in this
talk, we will be
talking about the
many ways developers
are using TensorFlow Lite.
But first, I want to
show you a video of a fun
demo that we built, which was
featured in yesterday's dev
note--
developer keynote.
This highlights the
cutting edge of what is
possible with TensorFlow Lite.
The demo is called Dance Like.
Let's roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Dance Like
enables you to learn
how to dance on a mobile phone.
- TensorFlow can take
our smartphone camera
and turn it into a powerful
tool for analyzing body pose.
- We had a team at Google that
had developed an advanced model
for doing pose segmentation.
So we were able to take
their implementation,
convert it into TensorFlow Lite.
Once we had it there, we
could use it directly.
- To run all the AI and machine
learning models to detect body
parts, it's a very
computationally expensive
process where we need to
use the on-device GPU.
TensorFlow Library
made it possible so
that we can leverage
all these resources,
the compute on the device, and
give a great user experience.
- Teaching people to dance is
just the tip of the iceberg.
Anything that involves movement
would be a great candidate.
- So that means
people who have skills
can teach other
people those skills.
And AI is just this layer
that really just interfaces
between the two things.
When you empower
people to teach people,
I think that's really
when you have something
that is game-changing.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIM DAVIS: All right, cool.
So to build Dance Like, as
I talked about yesterday,
we built ourselves
this audacious goal
of running five on-device tasks
in parallel, in real time,
without sacrificing performance.
And I want to walk you
through what they were.
So we're running two body
part segmentation models.
We're matching the segmentation
models in real time.
We're running
dynamic time warping.
We're playing a video
and encoding a video.
And let me emphasize
this again--
this is all running on device.
And to show you, I'm actually
going to do a live demo.
I spend a lot of I/O dancing.
And if we just cut to
the app, what you'll see
is there's a few dancers
you can choose from,
so real time in slow mo.
I'm going to like slow mo
because I'm a beginner dancer.
And so I can fire
up some dance moves.
You can see me--
the pose model running.
And basically
what's happening now
is it's segmenting me
out from the background
and identifying different
parts of my body.
And then, as I follow
along with the dancer,
a second segmentation model
starts running, but this time
on the dancer.
So now there's two segmentation
models running by the GPU.
And that produces
the matching score
that you see up in the
top right-hand corner.
And what that's
doing is giving me
some feedback on how well
I'm matching the dancer.
It's pretty cool, right?
But we went further.
Dancing is cool, and dancing
in slow mo isn't that cool.
So what we thought
we would do is
we would use
dynamic time warping
to sync my slow mo moves
with the real-time dancer.
And so what you get
is an effect where
the user, all running
on device, can
output this type of content.
So you can come and try
this in the AI Sandbox.
You can see for yourself.
You can get a video.
You can share it.
And it's really, really cool.
And it's all because
of TensorFlow Lite.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN:
How awesome was that?
And props to Tim for agreeing
to dancing on stage at I/O,
and not once, but twice.
So besides dancing, what
are some other use cases
that developers are using
TensorFlow Lite for?
The major on-device
use cases that we
see are typically related
to image and speech,
so things like
segmentation, object
detection, image classification,
or speech recognition.
But we are also seeing a lot of
new and emerging use cases come
up in the areas around content
generation and text prediction.
TensorFlow Lite is now on
more than 2 billion devices
around the world, running
on many different apps.
Many of Google's own
largest apps are using it,
as are apps from many
other external companies.
So this is a sampling
of some of the apps
which are using
TensorFlow Lite--
Google Photos, GBoard,
YouTube, Assistant,
along with several
global companies,
like Uber and Airbnb.
TIM DAVIS: So TensorFlow
Lite also powers ML Kit,
which is our out-of-the-box
solution for deploying
Google's best proprietary
models on device.
You would have heard
about this yesterday, too.
We are also powering
that in the back end.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN:
So now let's move
on to how you can get
started with using
TensorFlow Lite yourself.
It's fairly simple
to get started.
I'm going to walk
you through how
you can use an off-the-shelf
model, or retrain your model,
or use a custom
model that you may
have built for your own specific
use case with TensorFlow Lite.
And once you've done that,
it's really about validation
and optimizing your
performance for latency, size,
and accuracy.
So first, let's dive into
how you can get started.
As a new user, the
simplest way to get started
is to download a pretrained
model from our model repository
on tensorflow.org.
We have models for
popular use cases
like image classification,
object detection, estimating
poses, and smart reply.
And this is an
area where we plan
to keep adding more
and more models,
so please check back often.
These models that are
hosted there are already
in the TensorFlow
Lite model format,
so you can use these
directly in the app.
Now if you did not find a model
which is a good use for your--
which is a good fit for your use
case, you can try retraining.
And this technique is
also frequently called
transfer learning.
And the idea here
is that you can
reuse a model that was
trained for another task
as a starting point for a
model for a different task.
And the reason
why this is useful
is that training a
model from scratch
can sometimes take days.
But transfer learning can
be done in short order.
Note that if you
do retrain a model,
you will still need to
convert that retrained model
into TensorFlow Lite's format
before you use it in an app.
And later in this
talk, I will show you
how you do that conversion.
OK, so once we have a model
in TensorFlow Lite format,
how do you use it in an app?
First you load the model.
Then you preprocess
your data into a format
that your model will accept.
Then you change your
application code
to invoke the TensorFlow
Lite inference library.
And finally, you use the result
of the inference in your code.
So let's walk through some
code which shows this.
This is code which was taken
from the image classifier
example.
This is hosted on our website.
It's in Java, written
for the Android platform.
You can see that the first
thing that we do here
is that we load
the model, and then
we construct the TensorFlow
Lite interpreter.
We then load the image
data and preprocess it.
And you'll notice that
we're using a byte buffer.
And the reason we're doing that
is to optimize for performance.
Next step is to run inference
and classify the images.
And that's it.
That's all you need to do to get
an image classifier on Android.
I do want to highlight that the
example that I have run through
is in Java, but TensorFlow
Lite also has bindings
for Objective-C, C++,
Swift, as well as Python.
So the next thing I
want to move on to
is how you can use
your own custom
model with TensorFlow Lite.
So the high-level steps here
are that you train your model
with TensorFlow.
You write it out into
the saved model format.
And then you would
need to convert that
into TensorFlow Lite format
using TensorFlow Lite's
converter.
And then you make your
changes in your app
to use the model like I
walked you through just now.
So this is a code
snippet showing
how you can convert a saved
model into TensorFlow Lite
model format.
As you can see, it's
fairly simple to do.
It's a matter of
constructing the converter
with your saved model,
and then invoking
the convert function on it.
Please check out our website
for more documentation on this.
And it also has documentation
on how you can do this
with TensorFlow 2.0, which is
the newest release coming out
from TensorFlow.
Speaking of conversion, we've
heard feedback from our users
that TensorFlow Lite
conversion is sometimes hard.
Developers sometimes
run into issues
that the ops that
their models are using
are not supported
with TensorFlow Lite.
Or they might be
using semantics,
which we don't support yet,
for example, control flows.
Rest assured that we've
heard this feedback,
and we are actively
working to improve it.
We are building a
brand new converter.
This converter is based on
MLIR, which is Google's latest
compiler infrastructure.
And our new converter
will be a lot more
extensible and easy
to use and debug.
So that was all about how
you can convert and deploy
your model with TensorFlow Lite.
I want to walk through some
advanced techniques, which
you may use if they
are useful for you.
So many developers who
use TensorFlow Lite
care deeply about keeping
the binary footprint small.
Selective registration
is one feature
that can really help here.
And the idea is that you
can only link in the ops
that your model is using.
And this thereby makes the
size of the binary small.
So let's see how
this works in code.
You create a custom
op resolver, and you
replace TensorFlow Lite's
built-in op resolver with it.
And then, in your build
file, you specify your model
and the custom op resolver
that you just created.
And then TensorFlow Lite
will scan over your model,
create a repository of ops
that are used in your model.
And then, when you
build the interpreter,
only those ops are linked.
And this in turn will reduce
the size of the binary.
Another advanced feature
that I want to mention
is TensorFlow Select.
It allows developers to access
many of TensorFlow's ops
via TensorFlow Lite.
The caveat, though, is
that it does increase
the size of the binary.
But if your use case is not
very sensitive to the size
of the binary, and you're
running into issues that you
need ops which TensorFlow
Lite doesn't support yet,
I highly recommend that
you check this out.
So this is how it works in code.
It's a small modification
to how you would convert
your model to TensorFlow Lite.
This is pretty
much the same code
that you would use
for normal conversion.
The only difference here
is that in target ops,
you specify the set of
TensorFlow Select ops.
You can find a lot
more documentation
on how to do this
on our website.
It also has
information on how this
is working under the hood
as well as usage examples.
We get a lot of requests
to support control flows
in TensorFlow Lite.
These are constructs like
loops and conditionals.
We're actively working
on this, and we
hope to share more about this in
the coming few months with you.
And the last thing that I
want to cover in this section
is on-device training.
This is an exciting
new area, and we
believe that this will open
up many new opportunities
for research and
product innovation.
We are working to add training
support to TensorFlow Lite.
And at this point, I
would guess that this
would be available towards the
end of the year for developers
to try out.
TIM DAVIS: Great.
Thanks, Sarah.
So now that you have your
model up and running, now
you need to validate it
and get it running fast.
To get started, we recommend
benchmarking your model
with our benchmark tooling.
This will enable you to
validate your model's accuracy,
size, and performance,
and make adjustments
depending on the results.
Before I do get
into that, I wanted
to share the key performance
goal of TensorFlow Lite,
and that is to make your
models run as fast as possible
on CPUs, GPUs, DSPs, and NPUs.
Fast is what we care about.
So if you don't know what
all those terms mean,
I'll explain them now.
Most phones have a CPU, and
many have a GPU and a DSP.
CPU is typically the best
option for simple ML models.
GPUs are usually really great
for high-energy processing
at fast speeds.
And DSPs tend to be best for
low-powered, complex models
that require very
fast execution.
It depends on the use case
and experimentation with you,
but the great thing
for TensorFlow Lite
is that it allows you to
execute your ML on all of them.
And our team has
worked incredibly
hard to have optimal
performance across all
these different architectures.
For example,
MobileNet V1 achieves
83 millisecond inference speed
on a Pixel 3 with a single CPU
thread.
Drop that to just
15 milliseconds
when you delegate that
across to the GPU.
So we have a lot more
CPU optimizations
coming in our pipeline to
get even better performance
across 2019, in addition to
more op support on ARM and Intel
architectures.
So what about the delegation API
is such an important mechanism
inside TensorFlow?
But you're probably thinking,
what is this magical API
and how does it work?
So the delegation API
delegates part of your graph
to another executor at runtime.
It accelerates any or all parts
of the graph If it can get
better performance and falls
back to CPU when it can't.
So here's a great
way to visualize it.
A graph is made up of
a series of operations.
And for operations supported
on a particular architecture,
TensorFlow Lite will accelerate
those if you ask it to.
If certain operations aren't
supported on that delegate,
it will fall back to
the CPU automatically.
So now that we've spoken
about the delegation API,
the Android Neural
Network API uses
it to standardize hardware
acceleration across the Android
ecosystem.
In P, it supports around
30 graph operations.
And in Q, it will
have more than 100
and support use cases
like image, audio, speech,
and others.
For example, you could
achieve 9x latency improvement
on the ML Kit Face Detection
model using the NN API.
And it's really easy to use.
You just flip the setUseNNA
flag to true, and you're done.
You will get acceleration.
Your graph will accelerate
where possible using the NN API.
So the other thing
we've done is we
released the GPU
acceleration ops using
Open GL ES 3.1 for Android
and metal shaders for iOS.
So this will give you a 2
to 7x speed-up in comparison
to floating point on the CPU.
But it does add a tiny bit
more to your binary size.
Oh, did I go--
no.
And so it's really--
sorry, I went backwards.
Anyway, we're working on
making the GPU faster,
is basically what
I'm saying here.
We love feedback, so please
reach out to us and let us
know what's important.
So Edge TPU is another example
of the delegation API working
with a custom ML
accelerator that
has high-performance,
low-powered acceleration
at the edge.
It accelerates
TensorFlow Lite models,
and you can find out more in
the Edge TPU talk tomorrow.
So now we've got a really
exciting announcement
around DSP performance.
We've partnered with Qualcomm
to enable DSP delegation
through TensorFlow Lite directly
for their 600 to 800 series
devices, which is hundreds
of millions of devices.
While we recommend that you
use the NN API in Android Q
and beyond, this
announcement just gives us
another option for accelerating
your models on the DSP.
You'll be able to include
a Qualcomm signed binary
and rely on the delegation
API for acceleration.
And we hope to have this
released later this summer.
So you're probably wondering,
well, what type of performance
can I get on the DSP?
You can get up to an 8.3x
speed-up delegating over
to the DSP on Qualcomm
devices, which is an incredible
performance boost that we are
excited to bring to TensorFlow
Lite.
This is just another
example of how
we are enabling
more accelerators
to work with your ML models.
Lastly, as I talked
about earlier,
you want to ensure that you
are benchmarking and validating
your models.
And so we offer some
very simple tooling
to enable this for threading
and per-op profiling.
And here is a way to
execute the per-up profiling
via the command line
with Bazel and ADB.
So this is basically
what you get as an output
when you are doing
per-op profiling.
It really does enable you
to narrow down your graph
execution, and then go back and
tune performance bottlenecks.
Now let's talk about optimizing
your graph using the TensorFlow
Model Optimization Toolkit.
We offer a simple toolkit
to optimize your graphs
and enable them to run
faster at a smaller size.
For those that
already understand,
we are adding more
techniques for during
and post-training quantization.
And if none of these
concepts are familiar to you,
don't worry, I'll explain.
So what is quantization,
you might be wondering.
Quantization is really
just the reduction
in precision on weights and
activations in your graph,
essentially reducing
from floating point
to integer-based numbers.
The reason this works
so well is that we
try to optimize the heaviest
computations in lower precision
but preserve the most sensitive
ones with higher precision,
so there is no accuracy loss.
There are variants.
Post-training occurs once
you have an outputted graph,
and during training, which
preserves the forward pass
and matches precision for
both training and inference.
So now you know what
quantization is.
The goal of the
toolkit is really
to make your graphs run
faster and be smaller
by abstracting all the
complexity involved with all
these differing techniques.
So we strongly
recommend that you
start with post-training
quantization,
as it's a simple flag
flip to utilize it,
and you can see what type
of performance improvements
you can achieve.
We've seen up to a 4x
reduction in model size,
10% to 50% faster execution
for convolutional models,
and 3x improvements on fully
connected and RNN-based models
on the CPU.
And this is how
simple it is to do it.
It really is just
a simple flag flip.
So in the coming months,
we'll be improving our support
for quantization
with Keras, enabling
post-training quantization
with fixed-point math,
and adding more advanced
techniques, like connection
pruning and sparsity support.
But one thing we really
want to emphasize
is that post-training
quantization is really
almost as good as
during-training quantization.
If you're an
advanced practitioner
and have access to the
model and the training data,
then during-training
quantization might be for you.
But for most,
post-training quantization
can almost have the exact same
effect on size and accuracy.
So here you can actually
see the difference--
and there's really only
marginal differences--
between during-training
quantization
versus post-training
quantization.
So, again, please try and start
with post-training quantization
first.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: Thanks, Tim.
So is TensorFlow Lite
only for mobile phones?
It is not.
TensorFlow Lite is already being
used in many, many products
which are not phones.
It is being used in smart
speakers, smart mirrors, vacuum
cleaners, and even small
space satellites from NASA.
It's because of this demand
that we see from our developers
and also the fact that
there are a huge number
of microcontrollers
that are out there,
we have decided to
invest in making
TensorFlow Lite even
lighter and suitable for use
on these platforms.
OK, so let's first talk about
what is a microcontroller.
They're essentially small
computers on a single circuit.
They typically don't
run an operating system.
They have very limited RAM
and flash, usually just
tens of kilobytes of it.
And they only have memory, CPUs,
and perhaps some peripherals.
And the way microcontrollers
are used many times
is that they are used
in a cascading fashion.
So they perform
lightweight processing,
and, based on the
result of that,
it triggers heavier processing
on some more powerful hardware.
So as an example,
a microcontroller
can be checking to see
if there is any sound.
And this in turn can
trigger processing
on a second
microcontroller, which
would check if the detected
sound was human speech.
And this in turn would trigger
processing on a heavier
application processor.
So at a high level,
the architecture
for TensorFlow Lite
for microcontrollers
is the same as what we
have for TensorFlow Lite.
We use the same model format,
and we use the same conversion
process.
The only difference here
is that the interpreter
is a stripped-down, lightweight
version of TensorFlow Lite's
interpreter.
We have been working on getting
example models ready for you
to use on microcontrollers.
We have one already on
the website for speech,
and there is another one
for image classification
that is coming out soon.
And these models have
to be pretty small, too,
as you can imagine.
If you go to our website,
you will find instructions
on how you can use these models.
And if you are here at--
sorry.
And it also has suggestions for
how you can procure hardware
to get started.
This brings me to another
exciting announcement.
We are happy to announce a
closer collaboration with ARM
on the development of TensorFlow
Lite for microcontrollers.
ARM is a well established and
respected leader in this space,
and we are very excited
to work closely with them.
We will be working
closely with ARM
on the development of
models, framework design,
as well as performance
optimizations.
The Mbed community is
the largest community
of developers in this space.
And we will be integrating
deeply with the tooling
there to make TensorFlow
Lite easy and performant
for them to use.
This is a relatively
new effort, and we
would love to work closely
with the TensorFlow community
to make this successful.
So please send us your
feedback, ideas, and also
code contributions.
And if you are here at I/O, you
can go to the Codelabs area,
where you can try running
in TensorFlow Lite
on a microcontroller yourself.
TIM DAVIS: So where
can you go and learn
more about TensorFlow Lite and
everything we've shared today?
So the first thing is we
really listened to you
and heard that our documentation
just wasn't good enough.
So we've worked
really hard on making
it a lot better so you
have the resources you
need to develop what you want
to do with TensorFlow Lite.
We have new tutorials,
better demos,
and a new model repository
available and live right now.
Just go to tensorflow.org/lite
to get started,
and you'll see our revamped
website that makes it easy
to navigate and find
what you're looking for.
Now, as an open
source product, we're
working hard to engage
with the community
and be even more transparent
about where we're headed.
That's why we've
published our 2019 roadmap
on tensorflow.org/lite
so you have visibility
into our priorities.
So please, feel free to check
it out and give us feedback.
We also have new code
samples and models
on the site for common
use cases, like image
classification, object
detection, and the others
that you see here.
So now we're excited to
show one last demo, which
is very unique,
fun, and shows off
the performance
of TensorFlow Lite
in a non-mobile environment.
So Sarah is going to be the
star of the show for this demo,
which will look at the virtual
try-on of glasses and hair
color.
And then we'll take
a look at what's
going on behind the scenes.
So Sarah, come on up,
and let's do this.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: So as you can
see, this is a smart mirror.
This was built by one
of our developers.
As you can see, this
is a touchless mirror,
which is operated
only by hand gestures.
It's running the
CareOS operating system
running on Qualcomm hardware.
All the machine
learning on this mirror
is powered by
TensorFlow Lite, and we
are accelerating it on the GPU
to get optimal performance.
OK, let's give this a whirl.
TIM DAVIS: All right, so
the first try-on experience
we're going to show you is
realistic virtual try-on
of eyeglasses.
So as you can see,
Sarah doesn't need
to touch the mirror
since it works
through a touchless interaction.
The embedded Google AI
technology runs in real time,
and is driven end to end
with GPU acceleration
for model inference
and rendering.
Those glasses are
looking awesome.
So now let's try
maybe hair recoloring.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: Oh,
I'll go for the blue.
TIM DAVIS: Oh,
that looks awesome.
This is enabled by a
state-of-the-art segmentation
model that predicts for every
pixel the confidence of being
part of the user's hair or not.
Sarah, you look great.
So now, why don't we
take a look inside?
What's going on
behind the scenes
to achieve this experience?
So for every frame, a TensorFlow
high-fidelity geometry model
is being run to predict
over 400 points on the face.
And it even works
for multiple people.
I'll show you.
So all up, this is an awesome
example of on-device ML
using TensorFlow Lite
on a non-mobile device.
You can check out the
segmentation models that we
have available on
tensorflow.org/lite.
And if you'd like to find
out more about the mirror,
please come up to
us after the show,
and we can direct you where
to get more information.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: That's
all we have, folks.
Please try out TF Lite if
you haven't done so already.
We would not have
gotten to this point
if it wasn't for our
developer community, which
has helped us a
lot with feedback,
as well as code contributions.
So thank you a lot.
We're really grateful.
[APPLAUSE]
A few of us will be at the AI
Sandbox today and tomorrow.
Please come by to have a chat
and try out one of our demos.
TIM DAVIS: We'll also be at
Office Hours today at 10:30 AM,
right after this talk.
Thank you very much.
SARAH SIRAJUDDIN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]